no cuz money Yvonne Hoffman an
entrepreneur in Berlin consults her
business partner in Baghdad doing
business in Iraq right now is not easy
terrain in general I mean all of them
not wanting to do share with other
Christian and this is what say nobody is
doing anything some kind of tourism
everybody that say was waiting with
fairness with that done something worse
will happen Yvonne Hoffman sells dental
products to government clinics through
her Iraqi partner skipped um old tribal
daily the government continues to call
for tenders dental products and medical
supplies are still in demand but we're
no longer seeing big contracts many guns
causing all shy bones and as valued
people are buying in smaller quantities
wooden Denzil fan gift that's why I
think the current volume is just ten
percent of what we've had up until now
and dismissing volumes leaked one of
their products is this material used for
dental impressions the Iraqi market
accounts for five percent of their sales
Hoffman says they can absorb the losses
for now but not if further conflicts
break out in the Middle East in Vienna
to lift is about to understeer gaga's
fish if a rock goes down followed by
Iran and Saudi Arabia if the market in
the entire region collapses then we have
a problem we have to think of something
else fast buddy
galen colucci from the German Iraqi
Business Association is the go-to person
for advice on investing in Iraq he says
business in the region has plummeted
drastically I'm constantly associates
people are only focusing on basic
foodstuffs now luxury products are no
longer being sold you can't be sure what
tomorrow will bring and that's why
investors are focusing on the basic
necessities which Tom Tyler does live in
concert Riyadh we're in Basel near
Dusseldorf where one company has been
overseeing construction projects in Iraq
for decades currently the company is in
charge of a project worth 34 million
euros a new waste facility for a
pesticide factory is to be built on the
Iraqi Syrian border but now work has
been suspended as is militias rampage in
the area so the ice the main reason for
stopping work was that supplies were cut
off and even the people on the
construction site were probably at risk
from the terrorists mention of debauched
it matric of Isaac affair that the
workers can't be harmed if there are no
longer on site ventana thousand mayor of
the Boche telecon in Okinawa Stu Ramadi
Fallujah University for being the
company received the contract two years
ago at a time when the situation in
certain areas was dangerous but that did
not determine otakon he was unfunny
drift there's a reason I set up a
business there are problems everywhere
when we went to Yemen the president was
murdered well not by us but even in
other countries where we've been like
Nigeria there were problems using guns
and an under gear the yard over
we simply set up shop where our services
were needed Dean sticker Flash Gordon
back in Berlin to the Hoffman company
the big question is how the situation
will unfold in Iraq at the problem that
we don't think that the new government
can do something because then now I mean
nothing happened also there is a lot of
problems between the politicians
themselves and even inside the power
monitor dr. Yvonne Hoffman says the
safety of her staff is her first
priority business comes later